Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Conner's welcome to module one of the rife the frequency healing course
I say rife, but we're gonna be talking about all sorts of different types of frequency healing devices
But the main concentration is on rife
And you'll see why as we go through this so I hope that
These modules will be helpful to a lot of people especially those that purchase a rife from
But rife machine from us. So they feel like they're not alone
That's the whole idea of doing a course like this so that you can feel like you can best use a piece of equipment that I think can really help
So many health conditions and and so many people in your family every single member of your family
You should be running the rife literally every single night on somebody in your family and
running different conditions
During the day should you have a sickness so even if you're healthy, these are things that can keep you healthy
You know everybody wants to know what's a good wellness program
Well the rife is a great wellness program just by itself and
It can be far superior than taking supplements and
Can be just as important as eating right and thinking right and and doing everything else correctly
It should be part of your curriculum
The worst thing in my mind is if somebody purchases a piece of equipment that can be expensive and then doesn't use it
I just think that's such a shame
These are great pieces of equipment you need to be using these things and not take them for granted
We certainly don't want them to be
You know something like an exercise bike that you had to pay you your your laundry on or something like that
You want to use it and this is something that doesn't take a whole lot of energy to use
So you're not we're not asking you to exercise half an hour on an exercise bike. We're asking you to take
30 seconds and click a couple switches to turn on a machine that could really save your life
So let's get into the basics of healing frequencies
Again, this is gonna be basics. I'm not a physicist
I'm not gonna explain the differences in hurts and mega hurts and and
Killer hurts and all that kind of stuff. We're not this is it of course on physics
We're not gonna get into the different wavelengths
I'll mention that the true right that we use has a carrier wave
Any good right is gonna have a carrier wave that's gonna bring the healing frequency wave to the body
But beyond that, I'm not gonna get into the technical aspects of the machinery
I want this course to be be a user-friendly course not for you to become a
Rife specialist or technician, but it's going to be
Usable so that you can use this to help you heal. So this is coming from a from a physician standpoint
How do you actually use this equipment to your betterment to be able to deal with autoimmune diseases to cancer to live disease to
to brain issues to aspergers to
Just anything you can possibly think of you know comes down to frequencies and frequencies though
It may not be a panacea of all disease
It's certainly gonna help and that's the idea of this
One question that I get coming from a Christian perspective
Because I'm a Christian is as often I get people thinking that
Frequency healing is new age and
Is frequency healing new age? Oh, I don't want to get into the rife because that's new age of Tuesday and frequencies
That's that's about as ignorant as you could get and I don't mean that as an
To insult anybody, but you need to I had one person say no
I don't believe in frequencies. Okay. Well, do you use your cell phone because in order for you
To make a phone call you had to plug in some numbers which
Change to specific frequency that was that beamed via a frequency
From your cell phone to the nearest cell phone tower
Then that was beamed via a frequency to a satellite that's orbiting the earth that then that was beamed via frequency
To another cell phone tower nearest where the call you were making to that cell phone that person of that cell phone
Then that was be via frequency to that person's cell phone and so you might not believe in frequency
But you're surrounded by frequencies constantly
And it even gets deeper than that everything is frequency
Understand everything to its smallest particle by definition through quantum physics
Everything is just energy that's vibrating at a frequency. You know and Colossians
Paul wrote to us for in him all things were created all things were created through Jesus Christ
That's who the him is that we're talking about Jesus Christ created. He is the creator
And he is the sustainer of everything and God used frequencies
He created frequencies things in heaven things on earth things that are visible and things that are invisible
Whether thrones or powers or rulers or authorities all things have been created through him and
Unexpectedly this in your Bible for him they were created for him for his purpose and what are the purposes?
There's thousands of that millions one of the purposes and frequencies I believe is to help us with healing
Just like in the book of Revelation the different herbs are going to be in the new heaven a new earth are going to be for our healing
And they are today
as well and so are frequencies and how do herbs heal?
How do supplements heal? How do does a good diet heal? How does a good attitude change things and
It's all has to do with frequencies the frequencies that you're putting out. It isn't new age
Yes, new age people have hijacked the truth, right?
That's that's been from the beginning of age
the
Satanic forces hijacked the truth and use it to their benefit and twist it to turn it to their benefit
That doesn't mean that the truth is wrong if the truth still stands we need to bring it back and
Bring it back to what God created it for is for us and for him and for ultimately his glory
Ah
The book of Ezekiel says therefore
This is what the sovereign Lord says I am against your magic charms with which you and stare people
We are not to be using magic and we are not to be thinking that you know just because something we don't understand
Is now instantly new age and magic we have to understand these things and understand them like science not the way science has been
So poorly defined the last few years, but true science which you question things and you test things and you have
Observed what is in the natural realm and you're giving God the credit the scientists of the past
That's what they did gave God the credit
This is how he created things and it's a glory and a wonder that we could discover them and understand them
We are a million years away from understanding everything that God has created
And I truly believe that's one of the things I'll be able to do and have it
Aspen eternity to learn the wonders and the glory of God himself and everything that he created for he is
You know what he created to and as a we're gonna spend eternity learning that and this is never gonna stop
It's so deep and so to think that we should just label things
Because we don't understand them as new age because maybe new age will win us hijack things. That's just foolishness
And we're just you know
We're being fools when we do that
We are called to a deeper understanding Paul the apostle Paul in the New Testament said 19 times he used the phrase
Brethren, I do not want you to be ignorant
We are not to be ignorant of spiritual things. We're not to be ignorant of other things
So we need to learn as much as we can does that mean that we need to be a student of
Everything no, but we are supposed to have a curious mind and to be asking God for the truth in all things
Now a lot of people I understand that are gonna be listening to these modules are
You lost right now because they're not even professing Christians. Maybe you're agnostic. I don't care
We can still use these frequencies. I'm giving glory to God in them
So whatever you want to do, that's your choice
But I hope that through all my courses and all my writings
That comes through that I'm looking ultimately to give God the glory and everything because that's what my purpose in life is
Is to finally hear well done a good faithful servant and I hope that's the purpose that I can instill in you
So everything is frequency
Also frequencies affect matter. So matter is down to its smallest component
Frequency it's energy that's vibrated in specific frequencies, but frequencies themselves also affect matter
So we could use frequencies to affect ourselves to affect our organs to affect different tissue
To affect different microbes that are trying to attack our body to affect cancer
That's trying to grow in our body
We need to become wise. We need to constantly be searching and
Understanding and learning how what we could do and observe what we could do that could make a difference in our lives and other people's lives
I think that we're called to do that and we especially in this culture have really grown to become lazy and
That is slothfulness and that's not what this is about. So I commend you for
Buying this course and learning this stuff. So I'm not speaking to anybody that's in that category
Hope so I want you to just be constantly studied constantly learning and understand throughout these modules and all my courses
I call them living courses because as I learn different things. I'm adding videos. I've added information
You're not going to get a dig dig dig something's been added to your course
You need to be coming back to these modules and see if there's something you didn't look at yet
Oh, that looks new. I'm going to listen to that video or looks like Dr. Patterson added that information
I'm going to go and look at them these courses are constantly changing changing
When I when we're putting this course together, I just finished the stop fighting cancer course about three months ago
I've already made multiple additions to it
So that's what we're doing with all these courses is I learn things I feel like that's what my colleague is is I learned things
I got to teach it to other people I'll put it in videos and I'll add them to the courses
Doesn't mean that you need to become
You know a doctor of physics. I'm certainly not you don't need to understand physics
But just have that that primary grasp of what I'm saying right now helps you
To understand it in your mind. You don't need to prove any of this stuff to anybody else
If somebody is telling you that oh, you're crazy. You're doing the right for you're crazy thinking frequencies
Take the course for crying out loud. Don't listen to this. They sayers and skeptics and people who haven't learned anything
Since they went to school to have it read a book since high school
Don't listen to those people just because they have degrees behind there
They name doesn't mean they know anything look at all this medical doctors all they are as
Technicians for pharmaceutical companies. It's all they know how to do is give prescriptions and and use drugs
Crying allowed and they thought of a new thought in their life
Independent thought since when I get that their hands are tied and I get that
They can't do anything beyond the system or they'll end up with a lawsuit in their hands
But then break off and do something different
There's so many medical doctors that are now doing that now since his whole pandemic goof stuff has been going on
That has brought the doctors who really want to be doctors
To the surface that you could find these people and they're going into functional medicine practices on their own and that's fantastic
So find those people those are the people that you want to help you
Other questions do I need to learn technical skills?
Well, yes to know you need to learn how to turn on a computer you need to learn how to
Understand what a folder is in a computer program
It's true right that we use uses mainly Microsoft
Technology of 20 years ago or 10 years ago where you have to know what a folder is that you click on it opens up
A series of other programs maybe so yes, there's some skills that you need to learn don't be afraid of that
Again, you're supposed to continue learning
Do you want to keep your brain healthy and what a word off dementia learn new things novel skills
Get your brain working fire new neuronal pathways
That's the whole idea of why you're taking this course. So you don't need to be a
You know a super
technical
Computer whiz don't worry if you're technically challenged
You can learn these things. It's not very difficult
So all the stuff that we're going to be going through
And how to use your right should you buy what it's fairly easy and you'll learn it pretty quick
Do I need to learn all the different healing frequencies?
Do I need to know what number frequency of 512 hertz is?
No, you don't need to learn any of those things
So nice thing all these programs have been created and I'm creating a program for you
If you bought a right machine for for us and we'll find out what your made health challenges are
So I could put them in a folder and make it easy for you to be able to access
Again the whole purpose of this course is for you to be able to take equipment and then be able to utilize equipment
For your health make if it's too difficult to use you don't use it. That's why we're doing this course
Are there different types of frequencies? Yes, there's all sorts of different types of frequencies that most of the modules in this course are going to be out of rife
But there's other frequencies electrical frequencies ultrasound frequencies
Um
In front red frequencies all sorts of good healing frequencies and in the later modules I go over those
We use those things in our practice and we have in the 37 years that I practiced all sorts of different healing
modalities
I'm going to explain a lot of those so that you could go and seek out a practitioner that may have some of these other things
What's best to use when I you know really injured my shoulder?
Is it a rife machine or is it a pdf or is it a laser or is it an infrared?
Well, we're going to go over those in detail. We want to use the proper tool for the job
So it's the different tools you use for different things and that's what we're going to cover in these modules
Why is light frequency best? Well, it's not it really depends on what you're trying to do
So light frequency is best in my opinion using frequencies through a light tube a Tesla tube
Is best for killing cancer cells helping your body kill cancer cells helping your body kill parasites helping your body kill bacteria
Killing bacteria and sickle cell organisms directly killing viruses
Light frequency is
Hands down the best. I mean way beyond anything else. If you got a you know
Let's say virus
Will pdf help you kill the my virus? No, not really. Well, yes indirectly. It's pdf is going to stimulate cell health
Can that stimulate your immune response? Yes, it's not going to directly do anything to the virus
You have to hit the virus with its own frequency so you can destroy it on contact same thing with the bacteria
You can destroy a single cell organism like a bacteria or a parabesium with the rife
so
But you got to run no specific frequencies. You can't do it with the pdf
You can't do it with the laser you can't do it with with um infrared you can't do it with other things
But let's say I have a muscle pull is the rife the best for that?
Well probably not pdf would probably shine with that if I have a toward ligament what would be the best for that?
Probably laser would be best for that. We'll go over those details
But what you're talking about cancer when you're talking about health and healing with um with bacterial fungal
Lyme disease mold issues the rife with light frequency is far the best
And then what kind of health conditions can be helped with proper use of
The different modalities just about everything could be helped
Can it be cured? We can't talk about cure at all. We're talking about stimulating the body to do its job to be able to help you
so
Understand that understand our scope of what we can talk about with with making any health claims
But for sure using modalities to the best
um
You know the best use of how to use any individual tool. You can have dramatic changes in your health
And again the purpose of this course is to give you those tools so you could use these modalities
So you can boy, it's so hard to find a good doctor. I hear that literally
I'm not kidding. We hear that maybe three to five times a day
So hard to find a good doctor in my area
Well, you could just actually live in Chicago for quite a while. There's good doctors
I can't find them. I can't they're not taking patients or whatever
So the idea of these courses is to educate you so that you can now
learn how to be at least
uh, uh, uh, you know take the place of
Of a doctor that you might not be able to find
readily in your area or
To do things so that you don't have to go to the doctor maybe quite so frequency maybe that's a better way to put it
So so many conditions can be helped and we're going to go over a lot of these as the modules go through
all right
Continue to remember these are living courses so continue to check back with them
Know that I pray in for you and go through the videos and information
This module we'll see you at the next module